real quick before we get into the season
three recap if you need a season two
recap of succession just hit the little
tab in the upper right hand corner it'll
take you to my season two recap season
three however picks up regular season
two left off with kendall dropping that
bombshell on national television
everybody's kind of in panic mode that
includes shiv roman tom carl jerry hugo
i'm probably missing one or two but most
of the figure heads from way star royko
they've all cut the vacation short and
they're waiting on one person logan roy
they're also waiting on some planes to
kind of disappear nobody knows the game
plan though nobody except logan when he
arrives he still doesn't answer the
question of where they're going just
getting in a van and heading off so they
can wait for the planes because
truthfully he hasn't decided yet back in
new york kendall greg jess and carolina
get in a car to head to waste star so
that kendall can quote take over the
company but when they get in the car
karolina reminds him that they're in a
company car and since he just opened up
the company to investigation he probably
is no longer an employee of the company
this leads kendall to ask carolina if
she's with him and when she can't give a
good enough answer he completely kicks
her out of the car now that kendall
seems to have his inner circle he along
with greg and jess head off but as he's
trying to gauge the reaction of his
bombshell he gets a phone call from
logan so he hands the phone off to jess
to kind of mediate and logan called not
to rip his son but to say hey decent
move hat tip but this could get really
bad for me so why don't you retract and
there's probably a deal here kendall
however doesn't give in saying that he's
going to talk to the government it would
probably be a wise decision for logan to
step down
that's when the conversation gets pretty
ugly logan then hangs at the phone call
and gets with all the figureheads and
jerry is going through just how they
play this with the department of justice
her plan is to do an internal
investigation tell the department of
justice they were completely blown away
by the allegations and they're planning
on thoroughly investigating them pose
the question do they actually have to
cooperate with the government romans
suggests they just don't cooperate at
all but jerry tries to let him know this
is the u.s government we're talking
about kind of have to cooperate we don't
know what they have or what they might
get logan ends up asking roman what's
our story here and roman says kendall is
exploiting these poor women and that's
sad but he's very unwell he's a junkie
he blew it in terms of the papers
they're fake or stolen if they even
exist at all and if they do exist you
can go after kendall for corporate theft
for roman the play is easy you
completely obliterate kendall logan then
asks about how the stock price is doing
and it's about the same but frank does
let him know that a lot of hedge funds
have already planned on what happens if
logan isn't there roman then asks what
if you just called the attorney general
and yell at him would that be okay but
logan says no we're gonna go above that
get me the president on the line they
then get ready to pile on into a plane
but as they're walking over to the
plains jerry lets them know that she
couldn't get the president she could get
somebody else but not the president and
logan doesn't want to talk to that
person so he tests jerry with talking to
this woman and finding out exactly what
the attorney general or the department
of justice plans on doing about the
accusations and the woman on the other
line lets them know that the attorney
general isn't the person they have to
worry about it's the deputy attorney
general a woman named marilyn but as
they're getting out of the van she gets
a phone call from kendall letting her
know that there'll be a spot for her in
the new company he also did this with
frank earlier so as kendall heads to
waystar he's trying to get his ducks in
a row the one thing about kendall is
though he's gonna have to find another
headquarters because just greg and
kendall realized that his access has
definitely been pulled he doesn't want
to get out of the car and be embarrassed
so with nowhere else to turn he's gonna
head to his ex-wife's house there's not
only a change of plans with kendall
there's also a change of plans with
logan they were all planning on
originally going to new york now ever
since talking to that woman in the
government kind of freaked logan out so
he's changed plans completely the first
wave is gonna go to sarajevo which is
beautiful this time of year and the
first wave is gonna include logan tom
frank hugo and carl it's really just a
boys club the second group is to find
their own country logan provided them a
list of a bunch of countries and
figured out that it was all countries
that don't have extradition to the us
the only person not going is connor who
is tasked with staying back and quote
holding down the fort but before they
leave logan realizes he's probably gonna
need a lawyer for this jerry suggests
someone named lisa arthur she's got a
lot of credibility she's probably the
best in the business not only that it
also helps the fact that shiv knows her
she's kind of a friend because of that
he asks shiv to handle it get lisa
that's gonna require her to go back to
new york so scrap all those countries of
the extradition logan once again changes
plans and sends shiv roman and jerry
back to new york to manage the new york
operations everybody then piles into the
planes and wheels up they go their
separate ways while in the air logan has
decided that he's gonna have three
dominant firms on retainer that way
kendall can't hire him the next best
five after that while he's not gonna
have him on retainer he's gonna have
them doing something so it'll be a
conflict of interest kendall also can't
hire them he wants to get an emergency
board meeting together to talk to the
big shareholders and to ease their
concerns he's gonna tell them that he's
gonna step back as ceo so that means
they have to find a new ceo it's really
going to be a name only because logan
plans on having a lot of input on what
happens but he knows that to keep the
shareholders happy he can no longer be
acting ceo when he asks them to throw
out names carl throws out his frank
throws out his but the reality is this
is gonna come down to shiv roman or
jerry that's it and tom excuses himself
to go to the bathroom to call shiv and
let her know that logan is 30 000 feet
above the air trying to figure out who's
going to replace him he really called to
find out if she would even want it
because you're kind of walking into a
disaster but she lets him know
absolutely i want it when she returns
back to her cabin with roman and jerry
roman inquires as to what that phone
call was about and shiv lies but shiv is
unaware of the fact that frank just
texted jerry about the fact that logan's
picking a new ceo so whoever's gonna be
the new ceo is currently flying back to
new york logan and his group then touch
down in sarajevo head to a hotel and
continue to talk about who would make
the best ceo tom who had told shiv that
he had no interest in the job starts
saying that he likes all of the possible
candidates and that piques logan's
interest because he thinks that tom is
doing the opposite say how he likes
everybody when in reality he wants the
job for himself it seems like logan's
just kind of messing with tom and they
go back to talking about the three
leading candidates but that's when logan
gets a phone call from roman campaigning
for the job or at least kind of he tells
logan that he wants the job but if he
doesn't get it he thinks that maybe he
could learn under the tutelage of jerry
one person he doesn't think should get
the job is shiv logan hears him out but
as soon as the phone call ends he tells
the group roman's out logan then calls
shiv and lets her know that she has to
bring lisa home so as soon as shiv
touches down in new york that's the
first thing she's gonna do one person
that's already in new york is kendall he
sequestered himself in rava's house to
avoid the media and rava has been
extremely supportive kendall interviews
a pr firm although it seems like he
already has a pretty good idea of what
he wants them to do and he's waiting on
some other meetings which one of them
includes a meeting with lisa arthur it
does get a little awkward though for
rava it is her house it is her
ex-husband and kendall invites naomi
over but rava puts on a good face
although she does get really pissed off
when naomi orders greg to open up pretty
sentimental bottle of wine to reva
although rava just lets it brush off her
back lets kendall do what he needs to do
as i said very supportive but before
lisa heads over to meet with kendall she
gets a surprise meeting from her friend
shiv and right off the bat lisa lets
shiv know i can't give your father any
legal advice she tells shif she just
doesn't think she fits but shiv also
came for herself shiv is torn as to what
to do in one situation she comes out of
this thing as the ceo or she might have
to leave waystar to protect her
reputation shiv starts to kind of ramble
on the fact that she doesn't really know
what to do and lisa cuts her off and
says i cannot give you legal advice and
i do not suggest that you give me any
confidential information and that tips
off shiv that lisa has been hired by
kendall which blows shiv's mind
unfortunately shiv has to leave that
meeting and let logan know that lisa
isn't with her and now that shiv failed
logan ends up calling jerry and letting
jerry know that she got the job she's
gonna be ceo and roman is thrilled
mainly because shiv didn't get it he
actually calls shiv up and is gloating
about the fact that she didn't get the
job and that's when shiv and structure
driver you know what change of plans and
gives them a new direction to head to
later that night lisa heads to ravis
place to meet with kendall and right off
the bat lisa lets him know that this is
a preliminary conversation so no
confidential stuff and kendall does his
best to sell it telling lisa that he
thinks she's a superstar and she could
be the one to help take down logan it'd
really be the pinnacle of her career
while lisa's flattered she tries to get
more of an understanding of the
situation and what is going to make it
tough is the fact that kendall wants to
take down logan without implicating
himself he also doesn't want to damage
the company so badly that he loses
control in the shareholders meeting so
it's a very complex situation kendall
though tells her i will do whatever you
want me to do i'm your puppet lisa
starts giving him some advice and it
seems like kendall has found his lawyer
but it doesn't take too long for the
news that jerry is going to be the
acting ceo to start leaking out and
logan doesn't really care about that but
what he does care about is when hugo
tells him that lisa arthur is going to
represent kendall and he gets real
pissed off at that in episode two as
kendall is at rava's place trying to set
up shop he goes and asks greg about
meeting with greg's grandfather and
greg's a little tepid kendall confronts
him about maybe getting cold feet second
thoughts to hitching his wagon to the
kendall train greg though reassures him
that's not the case not to worry he's
just a little concerned about everything
he thinks he's too young to be talking
to congress again he admits to kendall
that tom has been calling him non-stop
and he's just a little nervous as all
kendall tells him i'm not going to burn
you and offers to set greg up with a
lawyer kendall then gets called away by
one of his lawyers and greg starts to
head home but as he's leaving kendall's
place or i should say rava's place he
passes by a trojan horse that was sent
by stewie as soon as he steps foot out
of the building he gets a phone call
from a weird number when he answers it
it's tom tom had to call from a weird
number because craig wasn't returning
the calls from tom's phone and as tom is
demanding to know where exactly greg is
and what he's doing greg sees shiv walk
into the building so as greg is telling
tom about how he's kind of just standing
there observing not really on either
side trying to play both sides of the
coin tom once again asks if greg knows
where the papers are but greg says no i
have no idea before greg hands up he
does tell tom you know that shiv's over
there right and of course tom had no
idea but he tells greg yeah no i know
but let's keep this between me and you
for the moment when tom gets off the
phone though he doesn't tell logan and
logan's freaking out he has no idea
where shiv is and his boat is quickly
taking on water he needs family unity
and he can't figure out where his family
is back over at rava's place though shiv
has made her way up the elevator and
kendall is thrilled to see her as soon
as they get alone kendall says i want
you to join me and ship tells them yeah
that's not why i'm here but i'll tell
you that what dad did to you that whole
sacrifice that was cold that morphs into
them talking about what kendall did and
how it was a snake move but kendall
trying to explain that he did what he
thought he had to do at the time after
they're done talking about the move
that's over shiv asks all right where
are these papers and kendall assures her
that they're safe and they're being
copied shiv tells him that what he
should do is burn the papers go
apologize to dad make nice nice but
kendall says no i'm not doing that come
on i want you by my side and shiv says
well then show me the papers but
kendall's gonna need reassurance that
shiv is in fact on his side to show her
anything kendall then gets word that he
has another visitor at the apartment
roman he tells the lawyer to send him up
but let's ship know you're the one that
i want and roman is really coming on
logan's behalf he wants to see what
kendall's up to even though logan did
tell him earlier not to talk to kendall
he didn't want anyone talking to the
snake roman wanted to see for himself
but he also figured that shiv might be
there so before heading to ravas he
headed to waystar and talked to jerry
about how to start his quote
apprenticeship he then headed over to
rava's and when he gets upstairs they
immediately go into roman pleasantries
if you will really just nothing but
insults when they finally get into
talking about the actual situation roman
tells them i'm just here to spy for dad
and shiv comes clean that she's just
there to get him to back down they then
realize they need to go to a more
private location at this conversation so
they go to kendall's daughter's bedroom
and kendall tells him let's gang up on
dad to take him down shiv asked why
didn't he come to them before but
kendall tells them that this was kind of
a spur of the moment thing he did talk
to a lawyer but the lawyer actually
suggested that he not do what he did he
then reiterates i want to team up and go
against dad and they reiterate why
they're there on logan's behalf but the
conversation gets interrupted because
conor has shown up it's not out of the
blue though kendall did call him as they
wait for conor kendall tells them that
ideally he'd want to make a media
appearance with all four of them
announcing that they're together and it
would completely kill logan connor then
walks in the room and tells shiv and
roman you know dad's looking for you two
and shiv tells him yeah well we're here
on his behalf and conor kind of chuckles
and says yeah yeah no me too with all of
them now in the room kendall goes into
his big vision how they're gonna take
waystar to the next level without logan
roy and part of the play is that under
the leadership of all four of them they
can really turn waystar around to just
being a good company and not the
cesspool that it's been under logan roy
selfishly kendall wants this to kind of
wash his hands of things because he says
that they all knew what was going on
that sparks a debate on how much they
knew or if they knew it all shiv says
she knew nothing but both kendall and
connor are like come on we knew what was
going on like deep down
we knew that stuff was bad
after that mini squabble kendall says
look i could do this alone but i want to
offer you guys a ticket to the escape
pod roman of course has some smart ass
answer but kendall says you're happy
that he put in jerry and roman says yeah
i think jerry's a good leader and that
sparks a snide remark from shiv who
thinks that she should be in charge
kendall then gets a text message and
tells the group it's my kids i just want
to go downstairs and give them a hug so
he ends up leaving shiv roman and connor
alone when he gets downstairs however
it's not his kids it's stewie with
sandy's daughter
and sandy on an ipad kendall asks stewie
how does this play from the point of
view of you guys and stewie asks him do
you actually have a case and kendall
says yeah i do so stewie opens the car
door and says good i mean we're all ears
but i'm telling you right now i don't
really see it dude but let's talk as
soon as kendall gets in the car he tells
sandy back me he tells him they offer
they made to stewie in greece they're to
stick with all of that plus
more power kendall tells him that when
logan offers them the board seats one
way or the other he's gonna end up
sidelining him but when kendall's team
offers him the same deal they actually
mean it so kendall wanted to talk to him
to avoid a contested shareholder vote
and as kendall is making his plea to
sandy downstairs back upstairs roman and
shiv are trying to kind of figure out
where each of them stand neither of them
want to put their cards on the table but
they're definitely both interested in
kendall's offer yet they won't admit it
they're both sticking with the story
that they're there for logan they both
walk over with an earshot of conor and
shiv does say you know with all three of
us back in kendall if we promise a few
seats to the others he's gonna be done
and we need to figure out what we're
gonna do because this truly is our
moment roman is hesitant saying i just
don't think logan's ever gonna fail and
shiv can't believe it laughing saying
he's not dad from 20 years ago he's dead
now makes mistakes all the time and
conor ends up agreeing with shivs saying
it's really hard to imagine him
surviving this if we back kendall schiff
says if they did this today than a
spooked board tomorrow they could
actually win this thing and roman's
concerned that if they did that it might
actually kill logan at that moment
kendall walks back in the room and says
all right where do we stand so shiv
starts asking about the scenarios of
what happens if they end up winning she
tells kendall if you do win this and
take him out i don't see us coming
through in the proxy battle and kendall
tells him that sandy and stewie would
back down he's already talked to him so
there won't be a contested shareholder
meeting there won't be a vote they'd
have a settlement kendall then goes
around the room and says he was going to
send me to jail and he would have done
the same thing to you roman and the same
thing to you conor
shiv honestly i don't really know if he
would have done that to you but what do
we really owe him here they then start
talking about what the shape of this new
company would look like i.e
who would be in charge shiv saying well
if i backed you i would need to be ceo
to which roman starts laughing at and
kendall tells all of them i'm sorry but
that just can't be possible i'm the only
one with that kind of resume i would
have to be ceo kendall assures them
though it's nothing more than an interim
chair there'd be new directors and then
after that they can figure out how to
split this thing up both shiv and roman
stand up and say we have some calls to
make and they head out shiv ends up
calling tom she talked to him a little
bit earlier but didn't tell him where
she was tom didn't tell her that he knew
where she was but this call she ends up
coming clean saying that kendall wants
him to band together to take down logan
and she wants tom's opinion on things
roman however ends up calling jerry he
knows that jerry is compromised because
if roman were to back kendall it
negatively would affect jerry in a big
way but he wants her opinion he asks her
if we band together who do you think
comes out on top me shiv kendall and
jerry says honestly none of you i think
you all get burned by this her advice to
roman is to stick with her she really
thinks they're building something great
when both roman and shiv walk back in
the room they're greeted by donuts and
who doesn't like donuts problem is the
donuts were sent by logan and it kind of
freaks them out a little bit kendall
though gets the group back on track and
says all right what does everybody say
let's wrap this thing up and we'll make
an announcement tonight and connor is
the first one to say i'm out which
kendall says all right that's fine we
don't even need you anyway you're not
needed well when kendall turns to roman
roman also says he's out kendall gets
really annoyed but roman says i told you
this whole time i was here to spy that's
what i'm doing after trying to convince
roman to change his mind he gives up and
then turns to shiv and shiv says i'm out
too i'm a dad and that's when kendall
gets really annoyed because shiv was the
one that he wanted he kicks all of them
out telling them they're making the
wrong decision and insulting them in the
process not the best look on the way
back from rava's place roman ends up
calling logan and telling him that he
was able to locate shiv and shiv wasn't
being a snake she was there to try to
convince kendall to burn the papers
logan tells them that he's flying home
tomorrow and he'd really like it if they
were all there to kind of show some
unity and that's going to include marsha
logan really needed marsha to come back
because of good pr so marcia came back
but she came back with her lawyer and
her lawyer sits down with hugo and
marcia explains to hugo that she was
humiliated at what happened so she'll
come back on conditions she wants more
power she wants more money this marriage
is literally being negotiated by lawyers
for her to stay and it works the next
day logan roy ends up flying back to the
states he's greeted by his family
including roman and the paparazzi are
snapping photos of the entire
interaction but shiv doesn't get out of
the car she's still pretty pissed off
that jerry is now the name of ceo so as
they drive off logan tells her that he
wants her to be president although when
shiv asks what does that mean logan says
it means whatever you want it to mean
and shiv gets turned off it sounds like
a fake title but in reality what logan
wants shiv to do is be his eyes and ears
to make sure that jerry doesn't end up
turning on the family and finally the
last person that we really haven't
talked about was what happened with greg
greg was legitimately concerned about
what he was gonna do as he was sitting
in his apartment talking to a first-year
law student who's a friend of his about
his options he gets a knock on the door
from a lawyer but the lawyer is from
waystar so he's hesitant to take the
legal advice from the waystar lawyer
that was sent by jerry he ends up
meeting his grandfather that night and
asking him to help him out at first his
grandfather doesn't understand exactly
why he would need a lawyer if he didn't
do anything wrong but greg says if
everybody else is heading into battle
with armor he needs some as well his
grandfather tells him that he will end
up getting him a lawyer and the next day
they go to meet with that lawyer a guy
named pew they sit down and pugh says
priority one is gonna be your well-being
priority two is gonna be to expose the
structural contradictions of capitalism
those are a lot of big words for greg
and all greg really cares about is the
fact that he won't get in trouble and go
to jail but it sounds like greg's
grandfather along with pew are gonna use
greg as an opportunity to look around
waystar and expose what they've been
doing wrong episode three takes place
about a week after episode two shiv has
taken over as the president and kendall
has been doing a bit of a media tour he
was asked about his relationship with
his brothers and sister and he just said
i hope they're in a good headspace the
article is being mocked in the office
jerry is taking over as acting ceo
although it's already making waves she
wants to actually have some control and
logan wants to make sure that doesn't
actually happen it puts carl in a bind
because jerry says one thing but logan
says another logan ends up getting most
of the people in a room they're going
over some daily stuff and then tom says
there's a rumor that kendall is gonna
come in so which logan says if he steps
foot in the building he's gonna end up
punching him schiff says that she'll
find out exactly what he's planning on
doing at this journalism dinner that
night but she wants to talk about what
they're planning on doing to counter his
attack logan loves the idea but they
don't actually get anywhere with it they
then go into try to getting the message
out about waystar changing one of the
ways they're gonna do that is through a
media town hall that's gonna be led by
shiv hugo and carolina have come up with
an amazing slogan
we get it all right it's a terrible
slogan but it's gonna have to be the one
they go with for now the meeting gets
interrupted by somebody who comes in and
says that they have fbi agents on the
phone wondering if waystar is going to
cooperate if they get a subpoena and the
answer to that is no logan tells the
poor girl tell the fbi to off and
jerry turns to logan and says i'm just
wondering when are we going to start to
play ball on this and the problem is
logan isn't planning on playing ball at
all and they have a shareholder meeting
coming up it's not the best optics jerry
tells them if we don't accept services
by the fbi there's going to be agents
here in about two hours ready to
subpoena us they could also subpoena you
to a grand jury but logan is steadfast
yeah screw him i'm not doing it
eventually in the meeting logan ends up
leaving which leaves just hugo carolina
shiv and roman and hugo and carolina
tell both kids that logan feels alone he
needs some help so what they propose is
a business interview really it's nothing
more than a puff piece though for one of
the kids to wax poetic about how much
they love their father and how great of
a guy he is since shiv is already doing
the town hall that's gonna leave roman
to talk glowingly about his father with
stories that he doesn't actually have
because they didn't have this normal
loving relationship but as hugo shiv
roman carolina are all discussing that
right down the hall there's somebody
who's really concerned and that's tom he
ends up pulling greg out of his office
and showing him a broom closet telling
him that's going to be his new office
kind of a half joke half serious thing
since greg did sort of go with kendall
and he picked his own counsel but tom
gets real with him for a second and says
i'm actually seeing a buddy about this
very situation he's a lawyer i'm gonna
get his take on it if you want you can
tag along and get some legal advice for
free
greg however has plans he tells tom that
ken is planning on buying him a watch to
say thanks so he's kind of busy and
later that night ken along with naomi
the girl from the pr firm he's working
with a couple other friends they all
pick up greg and they head to this
journalist dinner that kendall's gonna
be speaking at they're showing greg the
watch that ken is going to be quote
gifting him the whole time greg is
saying he really just uses his phone as
a watch doesn't really need it but
everybody's kind of peer pressuring him
into getting the watch when they end up
getting to the dinner the first person
that kendall sees is shiv he actually
interrupts a conversation between shiv
and her old buddy nate although for shiv
it's kind of a lesser of two evils
because nate was giving her crap about
how waystar treats journalists shiv does
what she's supposed to do she tries to
feel him out and see if he's actually
planning on coming in but kendall's
response is let him worry shiv tries to
make the case that him coming in would
be idiotic everybody needs waystar to
win the shareholder vote and that
includes ken so she tells him why don't
you just wait a week kendall then takes
that opportunity to apologize to shiv
about the nasty things he said at rava's
place and shiv ends up pitching kendall
once again on standing down and working
together with the family to enact change
within the company but kendall sees
right through it thinking that she was
just put there to get him to stand down
when shiv ends up leaving the dinner she
doesn't head home she heads to logan's
to give a report but logan doesn't
initially bring up kendall he brings up
the fact that shiv wasn't the one to
talk to the media about how great of a
guy he is and ended up being roman he
really wanted shiv to do it because
she's hers only daughter what he really
wants is for her to glowingly speak
about logan while crapping all over
kendall before she does that though she
wants to know exactly how bad it was at
waystar and logan plays it off like it
wasn't that bad a few bad apples here
and there but shiv knows that's not the
case logan was on some of those emails
logan reaffirms though that he didn't
really know anything yeah they played
rough with the odd union boss here and
there but he didn't know the extent of
what was going on shiv brings up the
government digging into their affairs
but logan isn't concerned about that at
all saying he can handle it after the
meeting with her dad she finally heads
home to meet up with tom and that was
the night that thomas to meet with his
lawyer friend he tells shiv that his
buddy told him it's very difficult to
see a world where he doesn't end up
going to prison so tom actually has an
idea get ahead of it go to logan and
throw himself in front of the court as
the sacrificial lamb if he's gonna go to
prison anyway he might as well garner
some favor with logan at first shiv says
no you can't do that you're drunk but
then she thinks about it for a little
bit and says you know actually it's
really smart it's very likely that
nobody even goes to prison but either
way you'll be in the good graces of my
dad but then she once again kind of
reiterates no you can't she's already
planted the seed though tom is
definitely going to offer himself up to
logan the first chance he gets so that's
what shiv did after the dinner kendall
headed home with his party they
continued to have some fun poor greg
found out that kendall wasn't actually
buying him a watch he was quote hooking
him up now greg has to buy a forty
thousand dollar watch to not make it
look awkward but during the after party
kendall gets an alert on his phone that
this television show that's kind of like
john oliver is ripping him and the host
has a propensity to rip him quite a bit
lately kendall's been really obsessed
with his perception in the media the
whole time kendall is acting like he
loves it but the pr firm he hired isn't
really liking it a lot that same pr firm
has instructed him not to go in they
gave him the same advice that shiv gave
him but the next day when he wakes up he
decides you know what no i'm going in
and this isn't going to be in a day or a
week no he's going in that day and over
at the office logan is waiting for the
senior white house aide to wrap up a
political show on atn when tom comes up
and offers himself up logan can't
believe that he doesn't want anything
for this but tom reaffirms that he
should be the one to be thrown to the
wolves logan tells him it's not gonna
come to that but thank you tom after
this meeting with logan though tom heads
to an office and ends up calling a law
firm to get a consultation but as he's
setting it up greg calls him and says
hey i have something that you guys might
want to know logan however stayed in the
production studio and waited for that
white house aid to get off they have a
good relationship with each other but
logan really wants to have a feeling out
process of how the president is feeling
about the whole situation at first it
starts off innocent enough but then the
conversation gets pretty contentious
while the president has a good
relationship with logan roy his
detractors have already assumed that
he's going to take it easy on him
kind of force their hand to not take it
easy on him logan thinking that his
buddy could do him a solid gets really
annoyed saying that the coverage on atn
could turn this is an election year
after all and the white house aide tells
logan well with all our cards on the
table it's not like the president has
appreciated your coverage in the first
place unfortunately for logan doesn't
look like the president is going to be
able to help him out at all and give him
a pardon while all of that's going down
in the atn office kendall is making his
way over all of this is at the behest of
lisa who is telling ken that he
shouldn't be doing this it's also worth
mentioning that ken has been telling
everybody he has a pardon from the
government and something that lisa's
working on but it's not set in stone but
ken is heading over and his family has
gotten word of this and they're freaking
out a little bit they've got a town hall
set in two hours and a snake slithering
in the weeds logan instructs security
that kendall's fired if he ends up
showing up he's to be cuffed jerry
reminds him the optics of that would be
really bad with the shareholder vote
coming up but firing him would end up
being a pr disaster it would also give
the doj all the ammo they would need
it's a little too late though because
kendall has arrived at this point and
logan is adamant that kendall is to be
kept out and security does their best
but it ends up being carolina and hugo
that end up getting to kendall first in
order to not really cause a scene
carolina ends up buzzing him up and
allowing him to come upstairs when
kendall makes his way upstairs he ends
up seeing tom and he tells tom that
there is a world where they can work
together once again because kendall
liked tom kendall ends up getting back
in his office never once seeing logan
and realizing that they might be trying
to freeze him out it's pretty cold in
there either way he's not leaving and he
actually instructs one of the members of
a security team to go pick up a bunch of
items the rest of the roys though have a
bigger issue it's the town hall this
will be shiv's first real public
appearance as president and she heads
downstairs in front of media in front of
a ton of staff everybody's there to hear
her address way star royko she starts
off right away addressing the
allegations that were made by ken but
then all of a sudden you start hearing
nirvana's rape me
blasting it completely throws shiv off
her game security starts running around
trying to figure out where it's coming
from and there are speakers set up
around the office and it's not stopping
it gets the point where shiv can't
continue and she storms off the stage
pissed off when she goes to kendall's
office there's the speaker equipment all
set up and that's the final straw for
shiv she ends up typing up a statement
blasting ken and she calls connor and
roman over to her apartment to sign it
just like ken earlier she wants unity
but the public statement is really
damning it calls ken a deadbeat dad it
calls him a drug addict none of it's not
true it's just cold and harsh and it's
something that neither conor or even
roman feel good about doing so they turn
shiv down but that doesn't stop shiv
from sending it out and kendall finds
out about it as he's waiting in the
green room of that john oliver type show
he decided to go on it at the behest of
his pr firm he figured it would be good
optics if he played along but when the
pr firm shows him the statement from
shiv he is deeply hurt he ends up going
to the producer of the show and asking
that they not talk about it but the
producer brings up that it would be
weird if they didn't mention it the show
goes live in 15 minutes and ken is
having cold feet he ends up completely
ghosting the show hiding out in a
control room sitting in the fetal
position reading the statement over and
over but that's when he gets a text that
might make him feel a little bit better
because the fbi showed up at waystar
royko and they're raiding the place
logan ends up finding out in his offices
he's talking to roman about the
interview that he did the puff piece
that he did sorry and at first logan
tries to do the same thing he's done
this whole time tells them piss off but
jerry tells them no no these aren't the
people you tell to piss off this is the
fbi with a search warrant they're coming
in all of a sudden logan's complete mood
has changed and he's asking for every
lawyer he can think of they figure this
might have something to do with the
conversation he had with that white
house aide it forces logan to completely
change his tune and he tells jerry and
everybody else cooperate let them in and
this could not come at a worse time
because tom is entertaining a bunch of
sponsors and he has to tell the group
that if they see some guys running
around here it's the fbi and they're
raiding the place but this does kind of
salvage ken's night episode 4 picks up
the next day and ken is reveling in the
fact that waystar was just raided he's
sitting there with greg and it just
doesn't seem like greg is really paying
attention and that's when greg admits
that he just got a text from logan and
logan wants to meet with him and ken
actually tells him he should go because
he's got weight at this point he must be
an asset he is going to turn you against
me but you're not going to turn against
me right greg and greg nervously says no
i'm i'm sturdy so greg heads off and
about an hour later ken has to hop on a
conference call and it's with jerry
frank roman shiv carl carolina hugo
basically all of the heavy hitters one
name that has been mentioned though is
logan although he is listening in the
background frank tells ken that the doj
investigation has caused a lot of
blowback for their investors one in
particular owns four percent his name's
josh aronson after the feds came in he
called jerry direct and told her that
he's thinking about switching over to
sandy's group and the reality is they
need that four percent so they need to
court this guy and by they i mean he
wants to meet with kendall and logan
together in a room kendall starts
pushing back on being in the same room
with his dad as most of the people in
the conference call try to convince him
that it's only a half hour and he should
do it they are four days out from their
shareholders meeting kendall though is
steadfast he's not meeting with this guy
if logan is in the room logan is pretty
pissed off and he was listening to the
call with shiv right before she leaves
to go back to the office he tells her i
want you on firewatch watch the
negotiations with sandy and stewie
carl's smart he likes to be liked it's
not good for our side so just keep an
eye on it so she heads back to the
office and that's where roman already is
he's sitting in jerry's office and roman
is continuing to try to have the same
relationship that he had with jerry
before but jerry is trying
unsuccessfully mind you to kind of hold
some boundaries roman though feels like
they kind of need something against his
woke warrior of a brother ken and he
remembered that when they went to new
orleans for his bachelor party they paid
off some hobo to tattoo ken's initials
on his forehead so roman heads off to
try to find that guy because if they can
get the pictures that would be a real
bad look for kendall roy a couple hours
later logan actually arrives in the
office and he tells frank that he has to
call up ken and try to convince him to
have this meeting with josh and since
frank and can have a pretty good
relationship frank is able to do it but
the way he does it is he tells ken that
his buddy josh doesn't like him nearly
as much as he thinks he also strokes his
ego by telling him that he gets to show
aronson who he is as a leader when they
hang at the call the meeting is set
couple hours later logan roy and kendall
roy meet on a tarmac and head off in
separate helicopters to go meet with
josh and try to convince him to stay on
their side and not go with stewie and
sandy they fly off never interacting
once so while those two are heading off
to try to save the company back at the
company shiv walks in and asked tom a
very innocuous question but he gives her
a weird answer and answer as if they're
not married but their employee and boss
and tom's been in a really weird
headspace since he proposed to logan
that he go to prison in fact when shiv
actually walks in on him he's
researching potential facilities he's
got like a top five she didn't walk in
the office though to hear his top five
she wants him to talk to this atn anchor
about changing his narrative on the
president since he decided to send in
the feds tom though is weary of doing
that as i said he's been in a weird
headspace and shiv all but demands it
not as his wife but as his boss she also
says can you get greg in line we need
him on the joint defense tom agrees to
all of it and shiv heads out back to her
office because she's got a meeting with
connor logan realizes that because of
what's going on he's going to have to
keep people happy people that actually
know who he is one of those people is
connor so conor's come in that day to
get his what they offer to give him is a
network mainly like a food network or a
lifestyle network or even some stocks
but instead of agreeing to it connor
tells shiv i just don't really feel like
dealing with you
you're not really in charge and he walks
out she gets stonewalled once again when
she goes to check on the negotiations
between frank and carl and stewie and
sandy she walks in and asks how it's
going and they don't really give her a
definitive answer kind of giving just a
vague response so she prize she asks all
right well what are we hung up on and
when frank gives her the answer to that
she kind of scoffs at it saying they
have bigger issues to deal with this
takes both frank and carl completely off
guard they weren't expecting shiv to
just walk in and start demanding answers
for anything after all they literally
created this position for a week ago a
shiv is ready to leave she says well
don't forget to keep me involved and
frank very condescendingly says we
absolutely will in reality frank ends up
calling logan and tells him get your
daughter off my back this actually
causes logan to call shiv and tell her
to back off which takes shiv by surprise
because logan was the one who told her
to keep an eye on the negotiations in
the first place she tells logan if you
give in to carl and frank then everybody
starts cutting me out there's a line
here but logan just tells her nothing is
a line everything's moving everywhere
and then hangs up whatever the hell that
means this conversation puts shiv in a
really bad mood she definitely doesn't
want to be the token executive so she
doesn't wait for tom to go talk to that
atn anchor she does it herself she
barges into a production meeting
basically kicks everybody out and then
tells them we don't really like how
you're treating the president right now
we want you to be a little more
harsher the anchor pushes back on it he
doesn't like being told what to do
especially by shiv he doesn't mind it by
logan but shiv is brand new but shiv
lays down the law putting it on the
table and saying this is how this works
we can waste our time cursing at each
other but at the end of the day you're
gonna do what we tell you to do and shiv
is right the atn anchor backs off and he
starts changing his tone about the
current sitting president so shiv has
been pretty busy tom meanwhile has been
trying to not focus on prison but it's
all he can focus on while he didn't
handle the atn anchor he can handle greg
after all he's always been able to
handle greg he walks into greg's
palatial office to try to convince him
to sign the joint defense agreement it's
the whole reason why logan called greg
over in the first place but at this
point greg realizes that he has a little
bit of leverage and he wants something
problem is he doesn't really know how to
ask for it and he doesn't know how much
he can get he actually told logan well i
mean what what exactly can i get but
logan reminded him this isn't the way
this works why don't you go back think
about what you want and then come back
to me and if i can do it we'll do it but
by the time tom reaches greg greg has
already figured out what he wants he
wants his own theme park he wants to run
it work his way up a little bit but
still be an executive tom realizes greg
doesn't need me he knows what he wants
but that's when it hits tom that greg is
going to be running a theme park while
he'll be in jail the conversation then
takes a really weird turn from some
ancient greek story to tom yelling at
greg to wrestle him tom is obviously
trying to see if he can handle himself
in jail it's it's bizarre but greg does
agree to sign the jda so he is back on
logan roy's side and speaking of logan
roy both logan and kendall arrive at
josh's place logan wanted to meet
kendall on the tarmac to kind of map out
a game plan but kendall said no screw
that and showed up first this allows
kendall to talk to josh one on one and
he tells him this isn't really that
complicated i'm better than my dad but
my dad is better than sandy and stewie
he even pitches josh on an acquisition
for the company trying to do what frank
said and show that leadership but when
logan walks in josh kind of throws ken
to the side because the big fish has
arrived and this is the first time that
both logan and ken have been in the same
room together since logan asked ken to
go sacrifice himself in front of the
world and this first interaction is very
very awkward they try to play it off to
josh like they're fine but it's clear
that they're not the three sit down and
josh tells them that he has concerns and
they try to tell josh that he shouldn't
have concerns it's really that simple
josh then proposes a walk and they agree
because what are they gonna say no they
need to kiss this guy's ass he goes off
to grab a jacket and it leaves just
logan and kendall in the room together
and they don't say a word you could cut
the tension with a knife josh gets his
jacket and they start walking down to
the beach and he asked them both how is
this going to work i mean you're both
suing each other how can you manage a
company kendall points out that the
beatles put out some of their best work
when they were suing each other which is
a solid point they put out some bangers
but then josh suggests that maybe
kendall just walk everything back just
say he was mistaken say he was sorry and
get the family business back to being a
family business
and ken thinks that this was all
orchestrated by logan he starts
wondering if this was a ploy but it's
not it's simply a suggestion from josh
kendall's just being extremely paranoid
logan goes take a phone call and josh
ends up pulling ken to the side and
asking all right what do you have on him
but kendall says i really can't say and
josh tells him i understand you're in a
tough situation because if you don't
have anything you look like a fake but
if you do you risk me running away the
only thing that kendall tells him though
is he's implicated the three then sit
down for lunch and josh continues to go
in on the family asking ken if he wants
his dad to go to jail asking logan what
he thinks of ken they all say the
correct response but it's obvious the
two are putting on a facade they're
telling josh what he wants to hear in
the hopes that he stays with them at the
end of it josh just asked them can you
work together and they both say yeah
absolutely josh kind of laughs and says
it's tough i don't really believe you
guys and logan says it'll be okay
because kendall's a good kid he did a
stupid thing he thought it was right but
everything's gonna be okay we're gonna
end up having to pay him out and in the
end i'll still be in charge but maybe
it'll be him one day and maybe he's
actually the best of all of them and
this is a little awkward because kendall
is literally sitting right next to his
dad as his dad talks about him either
way josh says it's nice to hear he then
gives logan his demands on what he wants
in order to come their way all of which
logan agrees to they start walking back
but logan and kendall are pretty far
behind and it gives the two an
opportunity to talk to kind of leverage
one another logan telling ken that
greg's with him now ken tells his dad
retire now if you do maybe i'll go easy
on you conversation turns pretty nasty
after that but the more and more that
they walk the more that logan is getting
pretty winded logan however doesn't want
to ask for a golf cart to pick him up
because he doesn't want to look weak his
ego however ends up costing him because
he ends up having problems and kind of
collapsing a little bit as they sit
logan down to kind of get a breather
kendall starts pitching josh once again
and josh kind of looks at him with a
puzzled stare and says why don't you
just think about your dad right now ken
turns out logan was just suffering from
heat exhaustion he ends up getting back
to josh's place and getting back on his
plane to head back to the city while on
the plane he ends up getting a call from
the president because that atn anchor
was going in on him and logan tells him
that they don't control his editorial
freedom but he'll talk to him try to
convince him to go easy on him but it
would be a lot easier for logan to do
that if he didn't have this
investigation hanging over his head
that's what was going on on one plane
kendall on the other hand was on a
separate one and he gets a phone call
from roman now roman was able to get the
pictures of the homeless guy with
kendall's initials tattooed on his head
he had to pay a pretty penny for it but
he also has blow-by-blow information on
how the negotiations are going with
stewie and sandy and they're not going
well at all he calls up kendall to rip
him a new one for putting their father
in risk of heat exhaustion kendall tries
to brighten up his mood by saying hey
the votes in hand josh is a lock but
roman says no it's not we just got the
phone with him dad's little meltdown
scared him off he's going with stewie
and sandy he told us there was weak
leadership and it's fractured at the top
and it's all because you let him see dad
shrivel he also has zero faith in the
post dad leadership so he's gone and as
kendall looks out on the tarmac he sees
a helicopter arrive with stewie and
that's when josh comes up and gives him
a bro hug
in episode five we have the shareholder
meeting and it doesn't look like a deal
is going to be reached between sandy
stewie and logan and logan is in pretty
rough shape after his little spell at
aronson's and this is really stressful
for both sides both sides have spent 100
million plus to try to win this vote if
it does go to a vote but at the moment
it's way too close to call kendall ends
up going to wherever his team posts up
looks like a hotel room and gets a call
from frank who lets him know that logan
is perfectly content with going to a
vote which is really really stupid of
him frank called because he knows that
it's stupid and he wants to possibly use
ken as like a back channel to talk to
stewie and sandy so ken ends up calling
stewie up and encouraging him to try to
make a deal because he can't enact
change if the family isn't in control he
tells stewie i'm your biggest asset in
the company and i know that you guys
don't want to do this roll of the dice
chance any more than we do come on you
want something out of this sandy wants
to hurt my dad let's make this happen i
have an inside track of my dad and i
know that he's willing to take this
thing to a vote i know you guys are
angling for a better deal you have no
problem taking this to the brink but
you're not going to get a better deal
he's a narcissist he thinks he can get
on the floor say a few words and drag
back all the undecided and maybe he can
so go back to the table try to make a
deal and to the surprise of all the
figureheads of waystar royco jerry gets
a phone call from stewie to meet her and
while everybody's thrilled that they
might be able to avoid this thing logan
is curious on why they suddenly decided
to settle shiv tells them it's because
they know it's the smartest move but the
conspiracy theorist in logan thinks that
maybe they know something that they
don't know so he refuses to go he sends
shiv roman jerry and unfortunately for
frank he's gonna have to go out in the
shareholder meeting and kill time as the
group is heading over to meet with sandy
and stewie kendall ends up calling up
shiv and letting her know that a deal
can be made he gives her some tips on
how to handle sui and sandy and then
ends it with puppet master out the royco
figureheads get in the room and sandy
the older one is in pretty rough shape
looks like he dealt with a stroke and
roman jokes that he's nothing but a
vegetable at this point he's really
speaking through his daughter sandy it
takes a special kind of narcissist who
after nine months decides that even
though he's a boy and they're having a
girl we'll still name the child after
myself anyway they start going over what
they want in a possible settlement and
most of it is completely understandable
waystar agrees but the one thing that
they want that waystar doesn't agree
upon is veto control of a roy family
member taking over the company and as
you might be able to imagine that's
pretty frustrating for roman and shiv
jerry however tells them that the deal
is too good she has to go back to logan
with it she knows that it screws them
over possibly but they have to see if
logan's willing to accept and after a
quick phone call with logan he's not
chavez is there anything else that we
can do we're so close to this thing
younger sandy talks to older sandy and
says
we're going to have a think about this
and we'll get back to you now one of the
people who was left out of this meeting
was conor for obvious reasons and since
no one's around his dad he decides to
take this opportunity to ask for a part
in the company which is a bold move
considering they might actually lose the
company but he wants something to build
his resume upon when he runs for
president yeah he's still hung up on
that so just to shut him up logan seems
to agree to give connor european cable
he then gets a phone call from shiv
letting him know that seems like they've
been able to reach a deal they're really
close they're just waiting to hear from
the other side and when jerry sees that
shiv called her dad it doesn't really
sit too well with her by the time that
jerry shiv roman get back one person who
has suddenly arrived is greg greg has
had quite a day he stopped by kendall's
to apologize for doing the joint defense
and kendall lets him know that hey man
it's fine but i might have to burn you
he would only do it if he thought that
it could lead to bigger fish but he's
just giving him a courtesy warning and
that pisses off greg because greg was
told that he wasn't gonna get burned but
kendall ends this conversation with
saying that the only way that he would
guarantee he doesn't get burned is by
backing out of the joint defense greg
doesn't say anything he just walks out
because he has another meeting he has to
go meet with his grandfather and pew and
his grandfather is way more pissed off
than ken ken played it cool calm
collected his grandfather however feels
like greg slapped his good friend pew in
the face because he's known pew for 50
years it doesn't sit well with him that
his grandson came asked him for help and
then decided to go join the joint
defense without even so much as a
courtesy call after the conversation he
had with ken greg starts asking for
maybe a little bit of money to cover his
backsides on both situations but that's
when his grandfather tells him that he's
donating all of his money to greenpeace
and that includes greg's inheritance so
by the time greg shows up at the
shareholder meeting he's not in the best
mood but he's not the only one because
logan's mood has suddenly turned he's
acting weird when the group comes back
everybody's celebrating the fact that
they're so close to a settlement but
logan says nah something's screwy and
demands that sandy and stewie and sandy
don't be let in the building he has to
be talked off the ledge from this absurd
behavior a little while later jerry gets
a phone call from sandy and they've
decided to change their offer instead of
veto power what they want is for the
royce to get rid of their private jets
which seems like a pretty understandable
request to everybody but roman because
roman is so incredibly out of touch
logan however doesn't give an answer
just saying i have to go to the bathroom
and it can't come at a worse time
because carl is supposed to go on the
stage and talk and he was kind of hoping
that at this point they had a settlement
agreement so when carl goes on stage he
sandbags frank and tells him hey we're
going to need you to kill more time and
then leaves when logan waddles out of
the bathroom he looks completely
disoriented the group is asking him for
an answer and all he says is him
and most of the same people in the room
cannot believe that he just scrapped a
settlement because of private jets while
they're trying to make sense of his
weird behavior roman continues to defend
his dad at every single turn saying that
he must know something he's six moves
ahead the group all agrees though he
definitely turned the deal down so shiv
has to call sandy's daughter and tell
her no deal as the group is waiting for
the vote logan's behavior continues to
worsen and worsen he's making odd
requests including having tom escort
into the bathroom every time he has to
go which seems to be every couple of
minutes but little do they know that
kendall is headed over there because he
got word that a deal wasn't reached he
is not happy he gets a call from stewie
letting him know that there was no deal
reached and he tells him just don't
worry hold tight i'll take care of it by
the time that logan gets out of the
bathroom for the second time
he is gone he's calling shiv marsha he
thinks there's a dead cat under his
chair i mean this dude is cooked and
that's going to find out that logan has
a uti and he probably didn't take his
medication which affects his state of
mind and this couldn't come at a worse
time because he's supposed to make a
speech and try to get all those
shareholders who are undecided back so
the group frantically calls for a doctor
to kind of salvage this thing but after
they call for a doctor then they start
wondering at what point did he get like
this was he like this when he said no to
the offer should they go back to stewie
and sandy and as they're discussing the
fact that they can't let him actually
take the stage that's when ken shows up
and he basically just screams at him
that they have to make a deal work and
then leaves the group sends jerry down
to the stage to try to get frank to
continue to talk but frank is done
instead of following jerry's orders to
stretch the speech he ends up
introducing jerry so she's the one who
now has to drag this thing out while
jerry is waxing poetic about how waystar
has changed their ways a doctor has
arrived he hooks up logan to an iv and
shiv is hoping that by any chance they
might be able to get him on stage to
just say a few words should have asked
the consultants on what she should do
and they tell her we strongly urge you
to try to settle she then takes a vote
around the room to see if they go back
to sandy and stewie and the only one who
pushes back is roman at first but
eventually he agrees yeah all right do
the deal so shiv ends up going to try to
track down sandy the younger one but
logan's assistant then gets a phone call
from the president apparently he's been
trying to get a hold of logan all day
and obviously they can't let logan talk
to him at the moment they end up putting
roman on with the president because as
jerry puts it roman is bootleg logan and
the president screams at roman for the
way that atn is treating him but lets
him know that he's not running again
he's done he's out which means that
logan roy probably just lost a big asset
but it also means that the president has
nothing to lose with his doj
investigation it's not the best news for
waystar now down the hall at this point
shiv has been able to get a hold of
sandy she agrees to the demands sandy
however wants to go back to her dad and
see if he'll agree to it and that's when
shiv tries to kind of talk sandy into
making an agreement right then and there
she starts off by saying it's a shame
that sandy her dad treats her like this
now she can't make decisions and then
she tells her that she needs a
like-minded individual on the board so
they're willing to give her group one
more board seat but that would also mean
that way star needs another board seat
and that would go to shiv younger sandy
is definitely interested in this she
tells shiv alright let me go see if i
can sell this but this is good so you've
got the two women with vegetables as
dads making the deals on their dad's
behalf and a little while later a deal
is reached when shiv gets back tom grabs
her and starts i know being real weird
to her and he lets it slip that the
reason he's all up on her is because
he's been tracking her ovulation in case
he goes to prison he wants to put a bun
in the oven because he figures it'll be
like a nine-month stint so he wants
something to look forward to when he
gets out totally backfires on him
instead of being turned on shiv is
completely turned off by it so their
marriage is still weird they end up
walking back in and sending carl down to
make the announcement that the deal was
reached when he does the whole room
erupts in applause but as he's talking
up walks can somehow they don't have
security to take care of this they just
let ken talk because they don't have
another choice the first thing ken does
is apologize for the actions of the
company he then asks for a moment of
silence for all the victims and then he
starts saying the victim's names the
only thing that the group can do is just
shut his mic off which they do and
kendall ends up having to leave the
floor to me who's just watching this on
television kendall looks absolutely
batshit insane but his pr firm ends up
spinning it to make it look like it's
better than it is they find the one
tweet that has a positive reaction to it
him and his team are reading all of
these tweets in the basement of the
building upstairs however the waystar
firm is celebrating the fact that they
were able to avoid a vote everybody
seems excited except for logan at this
point he's fully cognizant he's come
back and he's not happy about the fact
that shiv gave away a seat to sandy and
created a fourth seat she tells her dad
we talked about this adding another
person on the board me or
connor we couldn't risk a vote you were
awol i mean what would you have done and
that's the thing logan doesn't have an
answer he just says not that he then
gets close to jerry and tells her that
there's blood in the water sharks are
circling they need to be aggressive with
some acquisitions and when shift kind of
tries to butt in on the conversation
logan flips out at her yells at her stop
buzzing in my ear so that's a
clear indication that logan is 100 back
logan also would like to send a message
to ken he sends his assistant down to
tell ken that he wants to meet with him
but he just wastes ken's time ken is in
this room waiting and waiting and
waiting and then finally somebody from
waystar shows up and says ken he already
left he's not coming and when ken tries
to call his dad his dad ends up blocking
his number in episode six the way star
contingent is headed to a conference but
this isn't just any conference it's a
conference to pick the next president
republicans have to act fast now that
the president is going to step down in
six months so they have to pick who the
party is gonna back and thus who is
gonna win the presidency they're gonna
do that at this retreat and
waystar is a big part of it because they
own atn they can really push the
narrative when they get off the plane
shiv decides to get in the car with
logan and his assistant carrie who roman
is pretty convinced logan is sleeping
with and shiv wants to talk about what
exactly happened the last time they talk
to each other which logan just chalks up
as he was unwell but the big reason why
she wanted to carpool with logan was
because she really feels like she can be
an asset in this situation she used to
be a political consultant after all she
definitely does not think that roman
should be the mouthpiece after what
happened with the president and the fact
that he doesn't really have any
experience in this realm she's also
scared that the leading candidate is the
vice president because he sees his
chance and that's a dangerous situation
the group then arrives at the summit and
the guy who's running the thing a guy
named ron petkas ends up giving a quick
speech about how important this summit
is because he really believes that the
future president is currently in the
room which conor is convinced he's
talking about him but petkas isn't wrong
the leading candidates are in fact in
the room and they're all going to be
vying for the eye of logan roy michelle
and the white house aide comes up to him
and rips them a new one for putting
everybody in this situation because atn
forced the president to resign kind of
not really but then lets him know that
the leading candidate is the vice
president his name's dave boyer he's not
flashy but he's the safest option
everybody likes him he's just kind of
like mayonnaise you don't necessarily
ask for it but you don't complain when
you get it
as logan and michelle were talking about
dave roman gets word from some rando
that his mother is remarrying and it's
not to the guy that they thought she was
dating it's to some other guy this dude
named peter munion as soon as roman
finds out he walks up to shiv shows her
the invitation and says did you have any
idea about this and of course shiv
didn't i mean they've never even heard
of peter munion before
they figure if anybody would have known
it would have been ken so they call him
up and ken is extremely stressed out
lisa and her team try to get him
prepared to make a statement to the doj
but he doesn't really play ball
afterwards lisa has to tell him that
things aren't going great forum waystar
has now opened up their books they're
doing an internal investigation that
looks extremely legit and what kendall
has isn't nearly as juicy as he once
thought so kendall's case is kind of
drowning and kendall decides to blame
that on lisa when he gets the phone call
though he tries to play it off like he's
not sitting here drowning although he
also had no idea about this marriage the
group trade insults back and forth and
eventually they just hang up on each
other but the fact that his mother is
getting remarried to some guy that
they've never heard of is consuming
roman he heads over to the bar and
starts googling who this peter munion
guy is but as he's doing so one of the
candidates named jared mankin comes over
and menken is the dark horse in the race
he's controversial he's not your typical
politician he kind of reminds me of
somebody from i don't know like 2016 but
can't put my finger on it anyway him and
roman really hit it off and the
conversation with mankind was a welcome
distraction for roman who was really
obsessing over this monument guy but
he's not the only person who's obsessing
over something greg can't focus for
whatever reason greg is on this trip but
he's very concerned about being burned
by kendall he texted him trying to get
an update but all ken responded with is
still weighing my options he goes up to
tom to get some advice on how to stop
thinking about possibly going to jail
but tom's advice is no great what you do
is all you do is think about it so that
when you finally stop thinking about it
it's a little respite although tom
constantly focusing on jail is annoying
the crap out of shiv she kind of yells
at him but then feels bad about it
because after all he might legitimately
go to prison she just doesn't know what
else there is to say so their marriage
is continuing to be in a weird place
that night tom is having trouble
sleeping so he decides to text greg and
they head off to a diner because tom is
quote in training he's found out that
the food in prison is a lot like diner
food so he won't start getting used to
it now so the two stressed out guys
start eating some hash browns and some
pancakes and some omelettes and that's
when greg asks tom if he'll fall in the
sword for him as well figures if tom is
already going to prison he won't mind
tacking on something else and to his
utter surprise tom agrees he doesn't
even really want anything in return he
just says that he'll do it so if push
comes to shove and greg ends up getting
burned by kendall he's just gonna throw
tommer to the bus but ken still hasn't
made up his mind and the next day along
with his lawyers he heads to make that
statement to the doj but it doesn't go
well at all in fact it went really
really bad as kendall and lisa walking
out with the doj people behind him
kendall starts making a scene about how
this whole investigation is how
no one's listening to them and how
they're all in logan's pocket the whole
time lisa is trying to calm him down but
he's not listening and finally when the
doj people walk away kendall says to her
i should put a rocket up their ass and
that really pisses lisa off she pulls
them aside and says do you think you're
smarter than me kendall awkwardly says
no and she says well you might be but
you're not a better lawyer than me she
then gives him the cold dose of reality
that he needs about what went down in
that meeting but kendall doesn't handle
it well in fact he ends up firing her
deciding to get new lawyers even though
lisa was quote unquote the best lawyer
ken kind of feels like that dog in the
burning building who just says this is
fine he knows that he needs to get
somebody to flip from waystar
speaking of waystar they're on day
number two of this retreat slash
conference slash whatever you want to
call it and that's when shiv gets
approached by her own candidate who
wants to kind of posture for the seat
his name is salgado and he's much more
of a normal politician and his pitch to
shiv is that he'll send her dad to
prison and put shiv in charge of waystar
he does it kind of in a half joking half
serious tone but
he's totally serious
after talking to salgado she walks over
where logan is holding court with
michelle ann petkis hugo
and carrie among other people and
they're all talking about how boyer
isn't probably gonna win his stock is
falling quick one person who overhears
the conversation is a connor roy
supporter who tries to throw connor's
name in the ring but nobody actually
takes that seriously and that's when the
three candidates boyer salgado and
menken start in on a pissing contest
with an earshot of logan it's one that
shiv actually gets involved with because
she can't stand mankin she's seen a
stick before and she just finds him
disgusting at one point salgado says
that this is what he does he's loud and
obnoxious and it's all to get on atn but
that's when menken says atn is a
dinosaur it's not even needed and while
logan roy is a legend he's no longer
relevant it's a bold strategy cotton and
we'll see if it pays off for him because
the group then head up to logan's suite
where they discuss who they're gonna
pick roman of course stumps for mankind
shiv stumps for salgado connor stumps
for connor in the middle of the
bickering between shiv and roman on
mankind and how much he is hated by some
people tom gets a phone call and it's
from ken ken asks tom to meet and they
head to the diner and that's where ken
asks tom in a roundabout way if he'll
flip he knows that tom is probably
headed to jail hell even hugo said that
the doj is loosening their grip on the
case and that no big names will go to
jail except tom it's all thomas thinking
about ken knowing that he has to get
somebody to flip comes to tom with an
alternative but tom is still sticking
with the company line when kendall
brings up that tom knows that nothing
goes down without logan's approval tom
says ah i don't know about that
kendall's a little frustrated but he
sticks with his game plan tells him
about his new lawyers and then tells him
about granted immunity and the fact that
tom wouldn't go to prison if he flips
tom then asked how does this work i mean
how am i supposed to look my wife who i
love and this family how am i supposed
to look at all of them and tell them
that i'm turning against them because i
come over to your side and ken preaches
some macho about how shiv will
respect him because he'll be the man of
the house telling tom that he should
bring shiv over to his side tom looks at
ken and says i don't mean to insult you
but my hunch is that you're gonna get
screwed because you always get screwed
and the reality is i've never seen logan
get screwed tom then starts walking over
his car and just to get some blackmail
on him ken starts snapping photos of tom
and tom kind of chuckles at the move but
as tom is heading back to the suite the
argument about mankind and salgado
continues to rage on roman feeling like
menken will really make atn pop ratings
will be huge with menken they won't be
with salgado so logan decides to talk to
all the candidates he calls up boyer
first and just to kind of be a dick he
asked boyer to bring him a coke like
he's an errand boy he then meets with
salgado and sogato actually passes tom
in the hallway as tom is walking back
but in the bathroom menken is being
prepped by roman roman does have one
issue though menkin is being labeled as
a fascist and it's not a great look so
he asks mankind if that's like a shtick
or is it real and menken says i don't
have a lot of boundaries i'll borrow
from anybody saint thomas aquinas hitler
i'm a man for everybody they they get
into a conversation about how menken
needs atn and mankin points out that atn
needs menken they both kind of know that
the other one is right menken then asks
about roman and where he is in all this
and romans says i've got some ideas for
etn kinda to spice it up go to a younger
demographic he talks about doing a deep
state conspiracy show but in like a
wink-wink kind of way but really all of
atn is set up for its star
president jared menken he then gives
mankind the tip about how boyer wouldn't
bring his dad a coke so megan's pitch to
logan is he brings him a coke opens it
and then he walks out the group then
discusses the candidates and roman is
smitting he tells his dad that we came
here looking for a horse and we found a
t-rex he starts pitching mankind as a
winner but shiv points out that menken's
a piece of whose chief of staff
broke a kid's jaw at a rally but roman's
pitch about how menken would be best for
atn works logan gives carrie the nod and
it's set mankind will be the candidate
that they back and shiv is absolutely
dumbfounded that they're gonna go with
this guy in the morning everybody at the
conference ends up getting breakfast and
carrie gives logan the update that
everybody's getting on the mankin train
shiv then gets word that everybody's
supposed to do a family photo with
menken but she wants no parts of it
logan then walks up to her and asks are
you a part of this family or not so shiv
ends up agreeing to get in the photo but
she refuses to stand next to mankind
they take the photo but as soon as it's
gone shiv storms out and it's obvious to
mankind that he is not well liked by one
roy in episode seven now that the
contingent of waystar is back and it
looks like the doj is loosening their
grip they want to make their big
acquisition it's a company called gojo
it's going to help their streaming
platform not suck it's an idea that
roman had but also one that ken had and
shiv had it's kind of the obvious
acquisition but shiv and roman are
completely stressed out they worked all
night on their pitch to the gojo people
to buy the company and now is the day
where they actually have to make that
pitch tom has to stop the infighting and
let him know that they did good work now
it's just time to execute as they make
their way to the board room they start
talking about the fact that it's ken's
birthday party that night and whether
either of them are gonna go the answer
to that is probably not because things
aren't great with ken at the moment shiv
then concedes the fact that it appears
logan is in fact having sex with his
assistant who's 50 years younger than
him which to her is crepey to roman is
awesome but then they enter the
boardroom and they're handed champagne
and they wonder if the deal's already
done without them they find out no the
gojo deal isn't done but they're
celebrating because of the fact that
jerry got word that nobody is going to
be going to prison including tom the doj
looked at the books looked at the way
that waystar was being cooperative and
realized that while it was a few bad
apples years ago there wasn't a
systematic problem going on everything
ken said was kind of overblown when tom
gets the news he quietly excuses himself
from the room he goes to that closet and
office that greg has gives him the news
and then flips the table and yells as
loud as he can an excitement over the
fact that he's not going to jail i mean
he kind of destroys greg's office by the
time that tom walks back into the
boardroom they're supposed to be meeting
with gojo mainly gojo's ceo
lucas matson but matson didn't show he
sent his cfo and a whole team of people
but the fact that he didn't send himself
sends logan off the deep end he takes as
a complete insult over the fact that he
won't even meet with logan so logan
calls the deal off and one of the things
that pisses logan off is the fact that
he knows that matson is going to ken's
party later that night so the fact that
he's meeting with judas but he won't
meet with logan really irks the hell out
of him shiv and roman though don't want
to just ax the deal because of this it's
petty they know the importance of
getting gojo for their platform they
don't want to be a dying media brand
gojo helps them avoid this but logan's
having trouble singing the forest to the
trees he tells both roman and shiv we
don't need gojo i had frank reach out to
nan about pierce again and shiv kind of
knows that that's a road that's going to
lead to nowhere when jerry frank and
carl leave the room shiv and roman
continue to plead with their dad to at
the very least not kill the deal let
them talk to the underlings but logan is
steadfast that he won't do business with
matson like this at one point logan says
hey carrie what was that thing you said
about matson and carrie says he thinks
he's a genius he's made one good piece
of tech
him and shiv is disgusted about the
fact that her father is actually
listening to carrie and lets carry know
that while they appreciate her input
it's not exactly good tactics at the
moment they eventually are able to
convince logan though to let them go to
ken's party and talk to matson there try
to convince him that this is a good deal
right before roman leaves the room logan
hands roman a card for ken for his
birthday so everybody heads off that
night to kennapalooza or whatever
douchey name that ken is calling it and
all of the roy kids are there including
connor he's sporting a coat and an
injured arm because he got good polling
news and he started dancing and slipped
and fell and he won't take his coat off
which is a problem because when you
enter the place they're supposed to take
your phone and your coat which none of
the roy kids abide to they then enter
the party and see what a complete douche
fest it is i mean it is
extremely cringe-worthy one person
that's there that doesn't care how
douche it is they just want a party is
tom who's in a great mood he sees greg
and they greet each other by their names
saying hello my name's greg and i'm not
going to jail hi i'm tom and i'm also
not going to jail both those guys are
ready to party it up tom's wife on the
other hand is with roman shiv and roman
have a mission they're not there to
party they're there to meet with madsen
and get a deal done that's really it but
they do at least want to say hi to their
brother they find him in vip and if
things aren't douchey enough on the
party scene ken is sporting a bedazzled
jacket of the 1980s band boston although
he doesn't really seem to know it here
i'll put a side by side of the jacket
and the album covers so you can see the
similarities it's kind of uncanny ken is
hanging out with naomi when he sees his
brother and sister walk in and
immediately they start kind of trading
insults back and forth but in a playful
way roman gives ken the card that logan
gave to him to give him first birthday
but roman says it's from logan and roman
which isn't true as ken tucks it away
conor walks up so now you've got all of
the siblings there he then escorts them
into a somewhat art exhibit he tells him
that it's what he feels like society is
headed and it's giant news headlines
like failed sibling dies in tragic
jerk-off accident and it's got roman's
face then you've got another one that
says wife of tom wamsgan arrested and
shivs faces on that one conor roy
elected president of in a bag
and that one sets conor off he doesn't
find the humor in it at all shiv and
roman couldn't really care less about
theirs but conor is absolutely livid
after all he's running for president and
he's polling at one percent that was the
good news that he got the fact that he's
polling at one percent which is four
million people but conor feels like it
could really sway the race it's only a
matter of time before the party starts
coming to him looking to make a deal so
in order to appease his brother ken has
it taken down ken tells the trio that he
has to go circulate but he sneaks off
into another room and opens up the
birthday card and it is a birthday card
but inside logan has written cash out
off and he attached a term sheet to
buy out all of kendall's shares he then
goes and finds naomi and shows her the
card claiming that logan is trying to
screw with his mind naomi inquires to
how much money that is and ken says it's
two billion dollars but what it really
is is just logan trying to screw with
his mind naomi asks him yeah but what if
you do take it you know because like 2
billion is 2 billion and ken says maybe
and then goes in a ridiculous scenario
of him buying all these newspapers just
to embarrass logan as both naomi and ken
walk back into the party comfrey one of
ken's pr team walks up and asks if he
has any idea where matson is because
both roman and shiv were asking to meet
with him now ken knows the real reason
why they showed up he tells comfrey to
have matson meet him in a place called
the treehouse so that he can keep madsen
away from his brother and sister a
little while later shiv ends up finding
out where matson is so they head up to
the tree house but they're denied access
they're greeted at the door by ken who
refused them entry he confronts him
about the fact that they're at the tree
house to meet madsen and ship points out
if we do talk to him we either strike
out and get nothing or we succeed and
your net worth goes up by a substantial
amount of money even with that argument
ken still refuses them access to the
treehouse he then thanks roman for the
card from him and his dad and walks back
in and shiv had no idea what they were
talking about she asked roman what the
hell was that and roman says it's
nothing it was a little move to ease him
out of the holding company and shiv gets
upset over the fact that she wasn't in
on this she is the ceo or ce whatever
her title is president maybe i don't
know but she's left in the dark and if
they're trying to buy her brother out of
the company she'd like to know as those
two argue outside
ken headed back inside to the treehouse
to meet with madsen who was having a
terrible time he tells him that his
siblings are looking for him but he
tells them that a deal with gojo doesn't
really make sense waystar buying gojo is
like amtrak buying tesla he actually
tells matson that what he should do is
by waystar and matson completely sees
right through it he then gets word from
comfrey that ravel wants to say hi so he
goes say hi to his ex-wife who brought
her new guy to the party gets a little
awkward rava asks him did you get the
gift from the kids and ken has no idea
what she's talking about he never got
any kind of gift rabbit tells him that
the kids made him something and it's
wrapped in bunny wrapping paper so ken
assures her yeah i'm i'm sure somebody
has it i'll make sure to get it rather
than mentions how the kids are being
bullied by waystar goons asked how much
ken yells at them and whatnot
ken had no idea about this so he tells
rather he'll look into it he walks out
of talking with rava and runs in a greg
and greg wants to talk to him about
something because he wanted to ask
humphrey out but when he saw her she
mentioned how she might have to brief
the press against him ken's talking
about putting a smear campaign and she
wanted to assure him that she was gonna
try to word it so it's not terminal kind
of killed any vibe that greg had to ask
her out so greg brings it up to him
saying how he was gonna ask her out but
then she mentioned this press briefing
and he wants to know if it's really
necessary because things are kind of
slowing down with the whole
investigation but ken tells him no and
she's out of your league which is
something that greg keeps hearing he
then flat out tells greg that greg can't
ask his employee out and then he says
some pretty mean things about greg he
walks away to enjoy the rest of his
party but he's completely unaware that
roman is gaining access to the tree
house he finds matson and immediately
starts pitching him on the deal and
matson admits that what's holding it up
is the fact that he doesn't want to
really work with logan roy he doesn't
want logan over his shoulder the entire
time so roman tells him that if he is
willing to sell then he won't have to
deal with logan he can go through roman
he can set up shop wherever he wants and
he can use roman as a middleman to talk
with logan until logan retires or dies
matson starts crapping all over the
waystar app and it's something that
roman agrees with so he says you know
what let's go take a piss on it he
escorts madsen into the bathroom opens
up the waystar app and throws it in the
urinal thing is about the app it takes
forever to load so he lets matson just
piss all over his phone slash the app as
matson is pissing all over his phone he
says so can i go back to my dad and tell
him that you're maybe interested in
selling to us and madsen says well if
all this is true then yeah they then
agree to meet on monday and roman asks
him if i shake your hand now can i go
and tell my dad that i basically bought
gojo matson laughs and says no but you
can tell your dad i'm in the
conversation so as roman was sealing the
deal ken was about to do his big
performance although he realizes that it
would be a really bad look the very last
second he ends up cancelling it he then
goes upstairs to where the presents are
being held and he frantically starts
looking for the present from his
children but he can't find it naomi is
trying to calm him down but it's not
really working finally she's able to get
his attention and gives him her gift
although when he opens it it's a watch
it's not a great gift because he already
has a watch after harping on the fact
that it's a pretty crappy gift he goes
back to looking for the present but he
can't find it and ken is slowly breaking
down a little bit so at this moment he's
realizing this whole party is absolutely
pathetic so ken's not exactly having a
great time somebody's night has turned
around is greg he runs into comfrey and
explains how he was planning on asking
her out but ken kind of put the kibosh
on that and comfrey isn't ken's biggest
fan he has her doing a bunch of menial
tasks and at the last second he ends up
bailing on it so she tells greg if you
want to ask me out do it craig does and
she agrees yeah i'd love to go out so
greg is on cloud nine he's not going to
jail and he did just bag a date with a
girl that is clearly out of his league
but over in the corner shiv has been
stewing this entire time about the
relationship between roman and her dad
she's a little bit jealous she ends up
finding roman and asking if there's an
update on matson and roman does the
typical roman attitude of not answering
but also giving her at the same
time and shiv's just over it roman
starts gloating to her about how he was
able to close the deal with madsen and
she was just left out in the cold and
she's just gonna have to get used to it
because that's just the way things are
they both start trading insults back and
forth and that's when ken walks by with
naomi because he's headed out and roman
just has to take that opportunity to get
a jab in at his brother ken walks back
and tells both of them you guys
shouldn't be here all you guys did was
come here to stab me behind my back and
by the way gojo was my idea now roman
turns his attention from ragging to shiv
to bragging to ken about how he lost ken
tries to tune roman out and turns to
shiv and says so you like spying on my
daughter your niece and shiv has no idea
what he's talking about and roman says
it's not a big deal and shiv is
mortified she can't believe that they're
actually spying on family but not just
family kids roman justifies it as well
ken's all been dad's business so we'll
be all up in his but that's a line that
shiv isn't willing to cross and it's
another thing that shiv was completely
unaware of that roman was privy to ken
ends up leaving shiv ends up storming
out and when roman finally leaves he
ends up calling daddy and letting him
know that he can get rid of the other
kids because romy took care of it
episode 8 starts out with a board
meeting stewie shows up as does female
sandy and they actually get called into
logan's office because logan wants to
let them know that they're about to
purchase gojo that doesn't really sit
well with them not the business idea of
purchasing gojo they like that that's
sound they just don't like the fact that
they weren't included and they were
supposed to be included in these things
but logan says that these things are
working quickly and that's why they
weren't included but it all makes sense
they then start the call and one person
noticeably absent is shiv she's phoning
in because she's still pissed off about
what happened the other night the other
person that phones in is ken even though
nobody really wants him to phone in
after the board meeting most the family
get ready to go to italy ken and his
kids go as do shiv roman and tom and on
the flight over roman brings up the shiv
about asking the mother if this is a
good idea he did some digging on peter
munion and he realized this guy's had
four failed marriages failed businesses
and what he's worried about is the fact
that his mother might be about to marry
a guy who's just in this for a cash grab
and nothing more but shiv who is still
pissed off basically goes with the
approach no i'm not gonna talk to her
screw it i don't really care so it's
gonna be up to roman to have this
uncomfortable conversation with his
mother now ken is the first to arrive in
italy with his kids and when he greets
his mom his mom lets him know that peter
has printed out this itinerary but she
doesn't want ken to stick to it because
logan and marsha are coming and logan
doesn't want to be anywhere near ken and
ken asks her what is your son getting
and what exactly is your ex-husband who
you hate getting and caroline says i
don't mind but peter does he has his
heart set on having all these important
people at his wedding and he doesn't
want to rock the boat so ken as he
should takes it as a huge insult and
walks away a few hours later everybody
else arrives and that everybody includes
connor and willa even greg shows up and
jerry and her husband and after getting
settled jerry gets a knock at the door
and it's roman roman asks she's heading
over to the welcoming party and she says
awkwardly uh sure let me just check with
laurie and then we'll head over and
we'll talk about the gojo price because
it's ticking up but right now it's not
an issue and laurie is jerry's husband
and roman starts joking about how she
keeps going on and on about him she's
probably obsessed she pulls roman into
the hallway and says by the way i've
been meaning to talk to you about
something you've got to stop sending me
dick pics roman tries to start
deflecting with humor but jerry says no
i'm serious i figure this is something
to do when you're under stress but you
gotta stop and roman once again deflects
with humor they head off to the
welcoming party and roman has an awkward
interaction with all petey munion
because the whole time he thinks that
peter is just into his mom for her money
when peter walks away roman brings up
the elephant in the room should she be
really doing this she kind of laughs
them off and then he says well you do at
least have an airtight prenup right and
she says oh come on don't be so
unromantic he explains that he's just
worried she's rushing into things and
she says what do you expect me to live
on macaroni memorial services and then
she walks off shiv comes over to roman
to get an update and he tells her
exactly what their mom said they both
then see ken enter the party and ken
enters the party with comfrey comfrey is
letting him know about the media request
form and none of them are that great
there is a podcast interview where a
bunch of former journalists are doing an
expose on the family kind of like the
kennedys and they're digging into all of
the family members not just ken
she brings up some of the possible
stories that they'll hit on and one of
them is the caterer who died at the
wedding when ken hears that he tells
comfrey maybe keep tabs on that one he
then gives comfort the okay to go enjoy
the party and she does she walks right
up to greg and kisses him in front of
everybody because i guess that first
date went pretty well she gets called
away though because something popped up
on her phone that she has to attend to
and greg then starts getting
congratulated by shiv and tom for
punching out of his weight class he
tells both thomas shiv that while he
does like comfrey he does worry that
there's no depth there and tom starts
joking around about the fact that he was
dying of thirst and now is suddenly he's
a mineral water critic greg then sees
another woman at the party and says what
about her i mean she's attractive and
tom and shiv start laughing saying yeah
no she's attractive but she's also like
a duchess but yeah man shoot your shot
they then they'll see roman walk up to
her and that kind of ruins it for
everybody the good time though gets
interrupted when everybody from the
family gets a text from carolina and
it's a lucas matson tweet that says
going to macau feeling lucky and no one
knows what that tweet means they start
trying to decipher exactly what this
means because the worry is the fact that
matson is trying to boost the stock
price of gojo roman ends up calling him
up but he doesn't get a response shiv
starts giving roman a lot of for
not being able to control his guy and
even kendall gets in on the roman
bashing now the head of waystar logan
has yet to find out about these tweets
he actually gets approached by peter
because peter wants to have logan help
him become a knight or
some douchey title logan kind of yeses
him to death to get him out of the way
but then kerry shows him the phone roman
walks up and logan's mood suddenly
changes logan's really not into trying
to interpret cryptic tweets he's
suddenly thinking that maybe matson
doesn't want the deal but both logan and
roman get interrupted when ken storms up
to him and he said you know what dad i'm
sick of this crap let's have dinner
tonight me and you eight o'clock let's
finally be done with this once and for
all logan says he'll think about it but
he ends up saying yes
knows most the family is dealing with
this matson crisis conor is dealing with
the fact that he's still running for
president and still thinks he has a shot
there's a political reporter poking
around at what willa's past job history
was and that could pose a problem for
conor and his campaign he knows this so
will actually suggest they do what they
used to do and keep their relationship a
secret she go underground but he says no
i don't want to do that and then he gets
down on one knee and he proposes now
it's because he likes her but it's more
for the fact that being married to willa
is better for his campaign she however
doesn't respond with a yes she asks can
i think about it that night most of the
girls hit the town for a bachelorette
party and it gives caroline and shiv
time to talk as mother daughter they
don't have the best relationship and you
see that when they both start kind of
insulting each other on you're a shitty
mom while you were a shitty daughter
even though ship doesn't have the best
relationship with her mother she still
is concerned peter's daughters took
shiv's phone pretended to take a photo
and exported her address book because
they're interior designers but they have
no clients so that's kind of the family
that caroline is marrying into so shiv
asked her mom please tell me you have an
airtight prenup caroline tells shiv the
same thing she told roman and chivas you
do have a good lawyer right and caroline
says yeah of course
they then move into the divorce between
caroline and logan and how logan ended
up with the kids caroline ends up
admitting to shiv i never should have
had kids honestly it's a good move by
you i mean some people just aren't meant
to have kids and suddenly shiv is all
about making a baby when she heads back
to the hotel that night she hops all
over tom she tells him that she wants to
have a baby but then starts talking
about business about how roman is ready
to screw this matson deal up and this
could be her chance she's gonna go out
and find a better deal for her dad she's
gonna show her dad the true value of
siobhan roy she tells tom we cannot let
roman become king and if i blow up roman
there's nobody left i take over they
then have this weird dirty talk thing
and they try to make a baby it's called
sex roman meanwhile wasn't invited to
the bachelorette party and i guess
neither was jerry because jerry walks up
to him and lets him know that his dad is
concerned with matson's deal falling
through so he won't send roman over to
switzerland to help figure out where
matson's head's at and roman knows this
is a big opportunity to save this deal
he has the best relationship with matson
after all and the reason that jerry told
roman and logan didn't tell roman
himself is because logan headed off to
meet with kendall to find out exactly
what he wanted they sit down for dinner
but when ken tells the waiter that the
one plate is for his dad his dad
actually gets concerned that ken is
going to poison him to the point where
he calls out his grandson to taste test
the food figuring that if it really was
poison ken would stop his son from
ingesting it he can't believe that his
dad actually thinks that he would poison
him ken kind of shakes his head but he
gets down to the reason of why he called
dad to dinner he wants out he's willing
to take his deal two billion dollars and
he wants some kind of asset like podcast
or outdoor advertising but he's out he
won't be on the board he tells logan i
won't even speak at your memorial
service i'm a ghost but to a surprise
logan says i need to think about it the
offer at your birthday was for fun
kendall starts shaking his head and he
says dad we can't keep doing this you
won and you won because you're evil
and evil wins i'm a better person than
you but good guys don't win and that's
when logan brings up the dead waiter
exactly what happened why they were in
the car together what they were doing
and the whole point of bringing this up
isn't to make ken feel bad it's to
remind ken about the fact that when he's
in a mess his dad cleans it up for him
so logan looks at ken in the eye and
says
whenever you screwed up i cleaned up
your mess and i'm the bad person screw
you and then he leaves the next morning
everybody gets up everyone's enjoying
breakfast connor asked willa if she's
made her decision she hasn't greg shoots
his shot with that duchess but that
doesn't go well because roman kind of
cockblocks and tom has a conversation
with shiv about what happened the
previous night he enjoyed having sex
because i hear it's fun but what he
didn't really enjoy was the dirty talk
the dirty talk was weird because she
kept telling tom you love me but i don't
love you and that just didn't really sit
well with him it was too close and too
real she kind of laughs at him and says
tom you can't ask people to say terrible
things and then get mad at them when
they say terrible things he then asked
her if she meant what she said about
having a baby and she says yes they
start talking about freezing her eggs
and then they have an awkward
conversation about what would happen if
one of them dies and eggs are stored
roman then flies off to have a
conversation with matson and it doesn't
go all that great when he meets back up
with the waystar group jerry stops him
before he goes in the boardroom to get
an update and he tells her that what
matson is looking for is really a 50 50
partnership he's looking for a merger
not a sale and because of that he
figures that the deal is dead jerry
stops him and says honestly this deal
makes sense and if we don't beef up soon
we're gonna end up being someone's lunch
they both walk into the boardroom and
roman is tasked with telling his dad the
bad news about matson but when his dad
asks him what's going on roman actually
sells it he tells his dad that a merger
is really just in name only somebody has
to be the top dog and that top dog would
be logan roy but everything that gojo is
doing improves waystar tremendously
they're going to have control of all of
these different things esports gambling
podcasts you name it they're gonna have
it at gojo so merging groups actually
makes a lot of sense now this would
dilute the family investment a lot but
even siobhan ends up coming around to
the idea logan's still a little bit
upset over how madsen's done business
but roman says dad that's what you would
have done he leveraged his position to
get into this situation it's actually
really smart so to everybody's surprise
in the room logan says okay bring in the
bankers it's at least worth having a
conversation about roman's doing a
little fist pump and he gets a text
message from jerry saying good job he
goes to respond with a dick pic and a
nice little message but instead of
texting jerry he accidentally texts it
to logan and when logan sees it he
bursts out of the room screaming i need
five shiv goes chasing after him to find
out what's wrong and then shiv sees it
she also sees her opportunity to
possibly get roman out of the good
graces she tells logan yeah there's a
weird thing going on with roman and
jerry everybody knows it jerry's
probably just not stopping him for
leverage but this is a potential problem
there's a track record here with roman
he then calls in roman and he reams him
out and roman is completely embarrassed
about the whole situation he doesn't
really have an answer when his dad asks
him why are you sending dick pics to
jerry it's a really awkward conversation
right before he leaves roman asks what
happens now and logan tells him we need
to fire jerry and roman says i don't
really know if it's good optics to fire
somebody for receiving my dick pics and
that's something that logan needs to
think about down the hall shiv has
pulled jerry out of the office to talk
to her about the situation and jerry
brushes off like it's nothing but shiv
says no it's not nothing you're not the
ceo of the company what you should do is
file a complaint with hr honestly you
should take this to the board now shiv
is manipulating the situation to try to
get control back but she sells it to
jerry like you're the ceo and if you let
the sexual harassment go to yourself
it's gonna look like you welcomed it
jerry however reminds shiv that
ultimately it's jerry's call to make and
she'll think it over in episode 9
following dick gate everybody returns
back to italy for the wedding only to
find that ken has had a suicide attempt
or at least that's the way it looks he
fell off a floaty and everybody's kind
of concerned about it everybody's
sitting around playing monopoly but tom
has to go forbes is doing a piece on him
because he's turned atn into a cash
machine and they want to know how he did
it and shiv jokes that he did it by
turning on the bigot spigot as he takes
off comfrey shows up and gives them an
update on ken he's showing up in a few
minutes the hospital released them they
really just wanted to observe him for a
little bit and everybody's kind of
walking on eggshells when ken does
finally arrive as ken grabs his kids and
takes off everybody kind of talks about
the fact that he does not look well as
they're discussing this logan
frantically walks by on the phone
talking to carl about something roman
tries to find out what it is and jerry
tells him that the doj is going to hit
them with a historic fine and gojo's
market cap has overtaken theirs because
of this gojo's board might be
entertaining other options so the gojo
deal is in serious jeopardy shiva tries
to get an update from rome and roman
doesn't really have one he doesn't know
what's going on either logan pops back
out and says he has to go see matson and
roman excitedly says do you want me to
come with and logan says no stay here
and play with your dick but when shiv
volunteers to go with all of a sudden
logan says yeah you know what roman you
do come with you actually know him and
once again shiv feels like she's been
left out in the cold so roman and logan
head off to go meet with matson when
they arrive matson and logan say hello
for the first time they've never
actually met but logan gets right into
it are we doing this deal or not and the
issue that matson is having is the fact
that logan and waystar are just too old
he turns to logan and says i don't want
to be rude you are a legend but we're
flying high right now and you're sinking
like a lead balloon and that's why i
make sense as the person to take over
logan has some you're not serious are
you and matson tells them i would make
everything nice for you i would want you
to maintain prestige not about making
you small but at the end of the day it
would be madsen's board logan looks at
matson and says i just don't know if i
can swallow this and madsen tells him i
get it if this is a family thing i
understand and your son i would need him
he'd be crucial to the integration
process that excites roman but matson
also tells him that as for the rest of
his quote team he'd be happy to assess
them according to their abilities so
he's not guaranteeing that they keep
their jobs to that logan says no matson
says i understand but if you want to
stick around maybe we can talk about a
asset swap or something and logan says
sure so he sends roman back to italy to
go to caroline's wedding and matson and
logan stay and try to see if they can
salvage some sort of deal roman gets
back to italy and meets with shiv and
connor they're gonna have a quasi
intervention with kendall shiv asked for
an update on the merger and roman
doesn't give one that's because roman
doesn't really have one a short while
later ken does finally arrive and
everybody tells him at the table that
they love him he realizes what's going
on and they say ken this is serious man
you tried to commit suicide but ken
plays it off like he didn't he simply
just fell off a floaty and that's it he
starts going around the table saying are
you kidding me you're doing an
intervention on me we should do an
intervention on all of you but shiv
points out that suicide trumps
everything
the conversation was getting pretty
contentious but it ends up cooling off a
little bit ken tells him i hear you guys
but do you guys have any idea how it
feels to be the oldest son promise
something and then just like that it's
gone
and conor takes deception to that
because technically he's the oldest son
you might not share a mother with them
but he is technically the oldest
although he never really had an interest
in being in the family business until
now so he lashes out at everybody at the
table screaming out he's the oldest son
and how he proposed to his fiancee and
no one congratulated him he forgets to
mention the fact that no one
congratulated him because he's still
waiting to get a yes from her so conor
storms off and gets ready to go to the
wedding and as he's outside waiting for
his car with willa he starts venting to
her how his family hates him he's gonna
lose atn in his campaign to a swede and
when that happens willow's gonna end up
leaving him so he's got a lot on his
mind and that's when willis says you
know what screw it fine i'll marry you
all of a sudden conor's mood completely
changes the happy engaged couple end up
heading off to caroline and peter's
wedding a short while after conor
arrives so does roman and shiv and roman
wants shiv to take one last crack at
their mom to see if maybe this is the
wrong decision she's making that day or
at least talk about the prenup and shiv
tells roman she has a prenup she had her
loyal look at it because she wants to
keep the london flat that logan gave her
in the divorce so that does put roman's
mind at ease well one person whose mind
is not at ease is peter munions because
a notable person has yet to show up
logan caroline has to walk up to him and
say he's just not gonna come you need to
accept it and be appreciated the fact
that i'm here so unfortunately for peter
he has to go through with this wedding
without logan roy in attendance as
caroline and peter tie the knot cousin
greg has turned into a wedding crasher
i'm talking like jeremy or john from the
movie wedding crashers he's sitting in
between that duchess that caught his eye
and comfrey neither of which know that
he's interested in both of them he's
more interested in the duchess and if
she isn't really feeling them then he'll
go back to comfrey but cousin greg has
become a player out in italy after the
wedding everybody sits down for dinner
or it might be lunch it looked like it
was a morning wedding and shiv gives the
most awkward speech imaginable but the
thing that's on both shiv and roman's
mind is the fact that they have been
left out in the dark with what's going
on with their dad they have no idea
what's happening and everybody that
makes a move that's close to logan like
marsha for example they suddenly go do
you think she knows what's going on
connor walks up and interrupts their
conversation tells them about the
engagement finally gets the
congratulations she was looking for but
says to him that will has been talking
to carrie and shiv cuts him off and asks
does she know where dad is and he says
no she's sandbagging but carrie has been
telling willa that logan has been trying
to up his sperm count he's thinking
about having a baby with carrie he's
been taking a bunch of nuts and roots
and all of this crap and suddenly roman
and shiv are like oh my god our 70 year
old father wants to be a dad again
tom walks over and asks what's going on
and shiv fills him in on the fact that
logan might be trying to have another
kid and he jokes that him and shiv
should get on it because now they're in
a space race and roman can't believe
that these two are planning on having a
kid he says to tom no she can't get
pregnant i know this because she's had
sex with so many men this enthralling
conversation gets interrupted when jerry
walks over and tells the group that
matson's financing guy's private jet
just landed then he's headed over to
matson's place it begs the question why
would matson's financing guy need to be
there for a simple asset swap jerry also
lets him know that greg of all people
has been contacted by a couple of
assistants she's trying to get a handle
on it she promises them she'll keep them
updated but now both shiv and roman are
in crisis mode roman heads off to try to
get carrie on the phone and shiv heads
off to try to find marsha before roman
does run into carry though he runs into
greg first he asks him about this
assistant talk and greg confirms that
there's a bunch of advisors in town
which is not good news
roman then speed walks over to carrie
but he gets stonewalled as to what's
going on shiv gets stonewalled by marsha
and when both shiv and roman reconvene
they know that this is bad it's at this
point that roman ends up being honest
with shiv for the first time and tells
her about the fact that madison did
float the idea of purchasing the company
and now shiv is really pissed off
because she can't believe that roman
heard this and then let their father
stay she walks up to ken and says hey we
have to talk and both her roman and ken
go and discuss the situation shiv tries
to pull the full story out of roman but
he's hesitant to actually give it and
she lays out what they're currently
facing the fact that their dad is with
carl and frank at the moment the market
cats have tipped there's a bunch of
advisors in town something is going down
but roman continues to say yeah i
understand all of that dad would never
sell they try to get ken's input on this
but he ends up just walking over sitting
down and he has a breakdown it's so bad
that shiv actually walks over to check
on him it's during the breakdown that he
tells them about how he killed a kid at
her wedding a few years ago at first
they don't believe it but then they
realize it's true and they try to make
him feel better any way they can but
it's not really working even roman is
pretty compassionate to his current
situation while they're trying to make
ken feel better shiv gets a phone call
from jaime laird and he lets her know
that he was cut out of the deal but he
confirms it gojo is poised to buy
waystar now they have to go face their
dad they hop in a car and they're
planning on just going and telling them
that they don't approve of this roman
cautions shiv though about going in
their guns blazing because they still
don't know all of the details she
screams at him do you still think dad's
protecting you because if we let matson
in control that's that slamming the door
on you roman questions if they can
actually stop him and ken points out
yeah we can a change in control needs a
super majority vote that was in the
holding company that mom got us in the
divorce dad would need us on board roman
is hesitant to do it he doesn't want to
turn on his dad but he gets convinced
they're gonna stage a coup they'll put
ken in the chair one of shiva roman is
ceo and the other one can have whatever
they want but it's a full on takeover
they all then hop on the phone with
roman calling conor to fill him in on
what's going on ken calling his lawyer
to make sure that this is ironclad this
holding company deal and shiv calling
tom to fill him in tom asks her where do
i fit in and she just says i don't know
high up there's a lot going on right now
he asked another question about where he
sits in all of this but she changes the
subject and says that when they force
him out they're going to offer him a
medical excuse and atn will go on the
air with it saying that logan isn't
feeling well he's stepping away and the
kids are taking over when he gets off
the phone with shiv greg comes up to him
and starts talking about relationships
but tom ends up ignoring all of that and
telling greg that there's a possibility
that things are about to change in a big
way and he asks greg if he wants to be a
part of it he promises greg a promotion
a chance to have a bunch of greg's
underneath him and that's very appealing
to greg and he is all on board a little
while later the kids arrive at matson's
place they store him in and they see the
whole team at work trying to get this
deal done they end up finding where
logan is walking in and logan is sitting
there with carrie carl frank and jerry
they asked logan what's going on but
logan doesn't want to tell them anything
with ken in the room he tells roman get
him out of here but roman doesn't all
three kids stay as a unified front they
want to hear it from their dad
themselves so their dad comes clean with
it that he is planning on selling the
company because this is the best time to
do it he's going to get out because the
company is taking on water it's a cushy
deal for him he's going to make about 5
billion on it he tells him our blood's
in the water and i have to make moves
fast i have to control the situation to
get myself and you guys insurances shiv
tells them once madsen's calling the
shots we're screwed but logan says no he
rates you and this is an opportunity for
you guys to get an education in real
life logan then goes up to roman and
says i've got you let's discuss but
roman tells him that i know what he said
but with matson calling the shots we are
screwed logan once again says no he
rates you this is an opportunity you can
trust me but shiv says you can't trust
him roman is very very conflicted about
what to do it's the first time we've
ever seen roman at a loss for words he
eventually mumbles the words please do
not do this and logan asks what if i
don't want to listen to you and ship
tells them we can stop you they then
bring up the holding company and things
get extremely heated between the group
logan asks carrie to hand him his cell
phone and he ends up calling up caroline
all the kids are confused on what he's
doing and when caroline gets on the
phone logan tells the kids that they
were looking over their agreement in the
divorce settlement and they realized it
was a little bit lopsided and it's at
this moment that all three kids realize
that the holding company super majority
was taken out at the last minute and
they are completely screwed shiv yells
at her mom you just cut our heads off
but her mom like logan continues to say
no i think it'll be all right as the
last ditch desperation roman says please
logan asks what do you have and roman
says i don't know love
logan stares him down and says you come
for me with love you want to talk about
love after what you just pulled you
should have trusted me because i win
he then storms out of the room roman
goes up to jerry and says jerry is there
anything you can do to stop him and she
tells him that her sole focus is in the
best interest of the shareholders of the
company so how does stopping him best
serve her interests and roman can't
believe that everybody's just stabbing
him in the back shiv meanwhile is trying
to figure out how their dad found out
about this and that's when she sees
outside of the doorway logan gave a pat
on the back to tom and it's at that
moment that shiv realizes that her
husband stabbed them all in the back tom
walks into the room and acts like he is
unaware of what happened and asks what's
going on
and shiv does tell him that caroline
screwed everybody over it's never once
mentioned that tom was the rat and tom
tries to comfort his wife but she feels
completely betrayed and that is the end
of season three of succession what an
amazing ending please consider
subscribing the channel hit thumbs up if
you like this video smash that thumbs
down button if you thought this
absolutely sucked if you want to leave a
comment i don't get back to you
don't take it to heart i just try not to
check the comments section because
usually they're a cesspool nasty
comments make me feel bad but please
feel free to talk amongst yourselves
that's fine i have merch i have shirts
and stuff so buy it don't don't really
care but if you know somebody that needs
a recap of succession season two or
three or whatever uh please send this to
them but just know i really appreciate
you guys checking this out